yeah what's going on with you and Ashley
man
oh yeah no super hot beautiful yeah
super hot yeah not so good you know I
think she might be a little racist what
do you mean dude she can't graces she
listens to pitbull by herself yeah
finer she's always complimenting me on
my English hmm Nicole I do you met your
English is on point bro very good very
good
I'm from Connecticut but still in spite
of that your English is good anyways you
think that's racist
no I'm dating Hannah right oh my god
she's a bombshell unimpeachable I feel
like something's sort of activated
inside that's what I felt I understand
where y'all are coming from originally
but things have changed
the other night during sex she start
calling me Django man Django from the
movie Django the slave
I was angry and hard as a rock man
unbreakable then after that she start
calling herself hunt you mom
no no I'm saying no right that makes me
uncomfortable and then after all that
she made us both pancakes oh wow oh I
get it cuz she's a character now I got
to commit to the bit you know I was mad
right yeah I couldn't even see straight
I was so mad what the thing was about it
their pancakes we're good slavery right
right that is right yes I think what I
need to do is break up with her smart
move I support you Yeah right after I
finish spending the next three to six
weeks mastering that recipe y'all could
come over afterwards so you want to hear
about racism you guys known Jennifer
what is she still doing the recipe
girlfriend awful yeah that's not every
time we hooked up she called it a drone
strike she would take me outside lay a
carpet on the floor called it a magic
carpet say hey Aladin why don't you rub
Thomas on my bed she took a copy of The
Kite Runner and
she took a towel she held me captive 12
weeks that's where you were I thought
you were in Turks and Caicos my feet she
violated at least five of the Geneva
Convention that was a hate crime yeah I
know I know but we do have the same
pants sighs yes no don't encourage that
what are you gonna do I'm going to break
up with her after that winter collection
comes in because she got no self-respect
the lot of you all right yeah guess what
you guys want to hear about some real
hardcore mean streets racism well one
time I went to go see maroon 5 tracks
that's up all right you want to
hear some racist huh you ready
so the other night right
[Music]
this table will clean yet whoa oh not
not yet but not yet what not yet
senorita Ashley white no words man geez
I gotta break up with her man even if
she does have laundry in her apartment
oh so I'm gonna go over there I'm gonna
be strong I'm gonna look her in the eye
okay and I'm just gonna tell her from
the bottom of my heart that we're gonna
spend the rest of our lives together
[Applause]
sorry guys but I think I have to go
clean my
Oh do we make the best decisions at
brunch oh my husband is Asian like me
[Music]